ils n'auront pas obtenu sa démission
mais dans l'espoir de ramener le calme
dans la capitale malienne
le président ibrahim boubacar kéïta
annoncé samedi soir la dissolution de la
cour constitutionnelle après plusieurs
jours d'intenses manifestations
j'ai donc décidé d'abroger des décrets
de nomination des membres restants de la
cour constitutionnelle est d'aller vers
la mise en oeuvre des recommandations
issues de la mission de la cédéao
tu continuerait de privilégier le
dialogue avec toutes les forces vives de
la nation pour la mise en place d'une
équipe gouvernementale consensuel
composée de cadres et vulcain et
patriotes et non de casseurs et des
monnaies serre du pays le mali mais de
mieux que ça depuis vendredi au moins
quatre personnes ont été tuées et une
cinquantaine blessées au cours des
manifestations les arrestations se
multiplient également dans les rangs de
l'opposition
plusieurs figures de la contestation
issu du mouvement m 5 ont été
interpellés après avoir appelé à la
désobéissance civile
nous restons mobilisés parce que la
déflation raffarin la détermination
continent avec notre modèle jusqu'à la
reine de la gym et bk qui maniait aux
abords d'un véhicule calciné devant
l'assemblée nationale
des centaines de manifestants appellent
à la démission du bk le président malien
ibrahim boubacar keita c'est une colère
qui éclatent au grand jour cristallisé
par le couvre-feu imposé dans le cadre
des mesures adoptées contre le
coronavirus ou encore les élections
législatives de mars et avril dont les
résultats sont toujours contestées
[Musique]
ce n'est pas tellement que la marque
mais notre pays mais nous sommes là on
avait passé notre économie mais nous
sommes là on jouait pas le nier nous
avons joué vers l'avant pour l'a400m la
regarde le monde et nous sommes
conscients des menaces tout en
appréciant hautement à la dépression et
à moi ça me rappellera possible dans un
pays en proie au djihadisme depuis 2012
aux violences inter communautaires et à
une économie en berne
cette contestation fait craindre aux
années du mali une nouvelle
déstabilisation dans une région déjà
très tourmentée